la chouette d'or c'est une chasse au
trésor qui a été lancé en 1993 par
intérim max valentin c'est un livre de
onze énigmes découvrira plus tard qu'une
douzième cacher mais qui permet de
trouver un emplacement précis en france
où se cache une chouette d'une valeur de
150 millions
salut ces dernières années j'ai par deux
fois abordé le sujet de la chouette d'or
dans mes vidéos une chasse aux trésors
mythique la plus longue la plus
mystérieuse qui reste encore à ce jour
non résolus mais des éléments nouveaux
m'ont donné envie de réaliser mon
premier documentaire complet sur un
sujet celui d'une vision qui a fait
fantasmer tout le monde et dont des
zones restent encore un peu sombre avec
notre équipe on a pu rencontrer le
co-créateur de la chouette d'or on a pu
voir les tableaux originaux qui ont
servi à illustrer la chasse explorer des
pistes et j'ai même pu tenir la cie
recherche est chouette d'or dans mes
mains la vrai de vrai non j'ai pas
trouvé d'acheteur je remercie par avance
toute mon équipe de chercheurs l'occe
mind et de shaker use ainsi que julien
alvarez des émissions du trésor michel
becker qui est le co-créateur de la
chaude nord ainsi que le domaine de la
pierre ronde qui nous accueille pour ce
tournage
bref toutes ces personnes sorties ce
documentaire n'aurait pas pu voir le
jour plus de 12 mois travail mon plus
gros projet de vidéo bienvenue dans
l'histoire vraie et complète d'une
chouette en or
[Musique]
la chouette d'or en fait c'est d'abord
un auteur d'énigmes max valentin bon
c'est un serbe ceux de nîmes c'est une
personne qui avait réalisé ses énigmes
et qui cherchait un sponsor pour
financer le lot donc ces énigmes il dit
les avoir rédigé vers
1978 donc ça date vraiment et puis
pendant un paquet d'années une quinzaine
d'années il s'est gardé un petit peu ces
énigmes et sasha sous le bras en
cherchant un sponsor pour financer un
lot d'ampleur cette sas au début la dre
dû s'appeler l'oeuf dort quelque part
parce que le lot devait être un oeuf
c'était l'offre du du père mais lui mais
il n'avait pas trop les sponsors pour
financer ce lot a alors depuis qu'il est
décédé on connaît sa véritable identité
et donc on sait aujourd'hui qui
s'appelle régis other il avait
effectivement utilisé ce pseudonyme max
valentin pour éviter des désagréments
qu'on imagine de chercheurs qui
voudraient confronter leurs solutions en
tout cas au mali lui soutirer les
solutions qu'il avait dû aider ce
pseudonyme qui gardaient un vrai secret
sur son identité il travaille dans la
communication et marketing et avait
travaillé pour des entreprises qu'ils
avaient organisé un petit peu des jeux
de piste des chasses aux trésors et que
c'est comme ça qu'on était venu un peu
cette idée de faire une chasse ça plus
inspiré évidemment de la mascarine le
mascara et c'était une chasse au trésor
qui a été lancé en grande bretagne par
un dynamique dit williams c'était un peu
le la première chasse aux trésors de ce
genre elle a été lancée en 1979 et dont
il y avait un lièvre nord enterrer un
livre des illustrations et la résolution
de ces énigmes permettez trouver
l'emplacement donc c'était un petit peu
le précurseur dans ce domaine là et donc
la chouette d'or qui a été sorti une
dizaine d'années après clairement c'est
inspiré du concept pas forcément du type
d'énigmes en tout cas de c'était la même
logique très clairement il avait vu un
petit peu le potentiel où l'intérêt de
faire ça en france ça n'avait jamais été
lancée donc il a été vraiment il s'est
inspiré de cette idée qui était une très
bonne idée et et la personnaliser et
l'adapter pour pour la france soit
voilà comment ils chassent les n'est
sans savoir qu'elle vivrait autant de
rebondissements parce que des hauts des
bas la chouette al en a eu et surtout
alors n'a encore mais la première
préoccupation d'un tel projet c'est de
se faire financer le lot qui à l'époque
valait 1 millions de francs soit plus de
deux cent vingt mille euros aujourd'hui
si on prend en compte l'inflation et
c'est là où on fait la rencontre michel
becker artiste peintre et michel becker
va financer ce lot en contrepartie de
quoi il va illustrer cette chasse au
trésor il va renommer ça parce que
l'offre d'or ça lui plaisait pas trop en
la chouette d'or du coup il change à la
fois le lot qui passe devant thor à
chouette d'or et en même temps il va il
va mettre ses illustrations en fait
il faut dire que j'ai été aidé puisque
au départ j'avais un très bon ami qui
était donc le pire aurait dû être le
sponsor de l'opération qui comme on le
sait s'est retiré je les ai je les écris
donc la dernière l'addition j'ai tout
raconté et lui au départ voulait lancer
une marque de joaillerie donc son
intention c'était de faire un objet qui
non seulement démontre son savoir faire
mais qui a une valeur si possible très
élevé quoi d'où la volonté dès le départ
de d'inclure trois kilos d'or dans cette
chouette quand cet ami s'est retirée moi
j'ai pris l'option de dire bon bain
givet quoi je me substitue à lui je
finance l'opération et c'est ça c'est ça
c'est que tous les matériaux to set ça
c'est toi qui as besoin de ça tout à
fait
je dois dire que le pour moi l'enjeu
était très important financièrement mon
but c'était de d'acquérir une certaine
notoriété en tant qu'artiste sa part
exactement fonctionné comme ça mais bon
c'est pas très grave sans lui en fait le
projet ne pouvait pas exister parce
qu'il fallait financer ce lot qui était
quand même une partie importante on va
dire de la chasse est donc en effet il a
eu droit un droit de regard on va dire
en tout cas non pas sur les énigmes
parce que cela elles sont restées
vraiment le la propriété intellectuelle
en tout cas c'est qu'il n'a jamais accès
aux solutions mais en revanche il a eu
en effet le droit de faire des
illustrations ce qui mettait en avant un
petit peu ça ça sa patte artistique il
eu un petit peu de pub en tant que
qu'artiste et 2
il a donné son avis il a changé le
l'autre lui semblait voilà plus
correspondre à ce qu'il ya quelque chose
qui lui plaisait voilà c'était vraiment
un projet commun dans lequel se sont
partagé il était conservé tous les deux
comme coauteurs même si la réalité c'est
qu'il y avait que 21 25 connaissez les
réponses et ils se partageraient à ce
titre les droits d'auteur tous les deux
on est clé de répartition que vous avez
fixé entre eux supérieurs pour michel
becker
en gros c'était deux tiers pour monsieur
mekerra tiens pour ma de valentin pour
tenir compte du fait que michel becker
avait financé le lot de financement et
trouverez mais les créateurs ne veulent
pas donner un simple chèque ils veulent
que leur lot soit une véritable oeuvre
d'art michel becker se retrouve face à
un défi inédit fondre ensemble des
métaux qui n'ont pas la même température
de fusion et surtout plusieurs chouette
vont être réalisés au lieu d'une seule
la chouette en or valait à l'époque un
million francs c'est une estimation
alors la chouette en aurait fait à peu
près 50 cm d'envergure et les fêtes
trois kilos d'or est à peu près 7 kilos
d'argent elle est sertie de diamants je
crois que le prix de revient qui avait
été donné un petit peu à l'époque qui
avaient été identifiées c'était à peu
près de trente ou quarante mille euros
et le prix de fabrication ça c'était
déjà là
28 ans donc juste déjà aujourd'hui sur
l'évolution de ces prix là on peut être
déjà pour cent mille euros donc on se
rapproche un peu de cette valeur de 150
millions après il ya une valeur on va
dire artistique qui l'a impossible à
chiffrer c'est un objet unique
[Musique]
donc des chouettes il y en a trois au
total il y en a au fond de moi je suis
en a créé trois j'en ai créé 3 alors la
véritable raison de tout ça c'est que
celle ci ne devait jamais à l'origine
sortir d'un coffre de banque où elle
devait rester jusqu'au terme de
l'histoire entre nous ça aurait été
dommage parce que quand on avait décidé
ça c'était pour 3 4 en cinq ans
peut-être 27 ans après on en rit
regrettait que jamais la voir mais bon
il était prévu qu'elles ne soient jamais
montrée au public ni en public et donc
j'avais fait deux bronzes un destiné à
être enfouis elle repassera en mariage
la contremarque qui est devenue la
contremarque et le second qui était
destinée à montrer aux cours
d'exposition à la presse etc pour voir
quelle était la taille comment était
foutue la chaux de fonds invité sur les
plateaux voilà exactement exactement ce
que c'est un défi technique en plus la
chouette d'or a réalisé l'alliage entre
l'or et l'argent du coup de l'or ça va
bien mais là que trois kilos d'or donc
ça veut dire que c'est le dessus des
ailes on peut la tournée d'ailleurs on
peut aussi on n'est pas obligé de
l'avoir toujours ça c'est l'angle qu'on
a l'habitude de voir sur les couvertures
et tout donc sur les ailes il y a
pratiquement trois kilos d'or un kilo et
demi de chaque côté cédé des pièces en
or qui ont été soudées sur la chouette
en argent celle en argent elle a été
fait avec les même moule que le bronze
ok en argent massif ensuite enfin massif
il ya un creux dans le bronze comme dans
l'argent en fait il ya un petit noyau
creux à l'intérieur mais pas énorme et
donc leur faivre a enlevé de la matière
d'argent donc sur le dessus des ailes et
à ressouder les pièces en or et la
prouesse c'était d'arriver à souder deux
métaux qui n'ont pas la même température
de fusion donc ça a été des soirées
compliquée avec
300 grammes d'or j'aurais pu avoir
exactement le même résultat visuel
j'étais pas obligé de mettre autant de
matières de faire les choses aussi
sérieusement mais le premier la première
victime entre guillemets de cette chasse
aux trésors sait moins c'est à dire que
quand il a été question de faire un
trésor dans mon concept personnel dans
mon inconscient personnel dans tout ce
que j'avais gardé de stevenson et c'est
un trésor
nom de dieu cela doit peser son poids
dehors sinon c'est pas un trésor ça veut
dire que j'ai effectivement pris ce
parti-là et mais en tout cas c'était une
démarche complètement presque suicidaire
j'irai d'une certaine manière quoi j'ai
tout mis dans la balance pour voir ce
que ça allait faire c
forme d'aventuré en quelque sorte
[Musique]
max valentin
n'avais pas d'idée préconçue sur
l'illustrateur il avait prévu en fait de
donner des instructions à l'illustrateur
donc il y avait un cahier des charges
avec les caractéristiques des visuels
qu'il souhaitait mais ses
caractéristiques elles étaient assez
succincte alors généralistes résume sur
une ligne de maximum
au moment où j'ai commencé à travailler
sur les visuels et j'étais moi même dans
une histoire de trésor c'est-à-dire que
ne connaissant pas les solutions des
énigmes je me suis finalement laisser
porter par les énigmes je les ai lus en
laissant mon imaginaire
finalement fantasmer dessus sans trop
chercher ce que sam évoqué g librement
pas en fonction de ce que je ressentais
par rapport au texte lui-même ce qui
fait que les visuels effectivement donne
une dimension encore très différente de
celle désignée
mon
on
[Musique]
des tableaux se termine comme vous
verrez tout à l'heure la chouette en
bronze est prête la chouette d'or va pas
tarder à être achevé il est temps
d'enterrer le précieux trésor et ça
c'est le boulot de max valentin qui va
partir seule en pleine nuit à 3 heures
du matin
[Musique]
alors la réalité c'est que personne
n'est capable de dire ça parce qu'il ya
une personne qu'il enterrait qui max
valentin qui aujourd'hui décédé c'est le
seul qui connaissait un les solutions
des énigmes et de l'endroit où il a lui
enterré donc la chouette d'or notamment
à 3 heures du matin dans 'la semblement
une forêt et voilà qu'ils en aient faire
on n'a pas de certitudes en revanche la
chouette d'or la vraie chouette d'or
n'est pas celle qui est enterrée pour
éviter que des personnes ne tombent par
hasard ce chouette d'or est bon même
s'il est enterré à 80 cm il a été
enterré une copie en bronze qui devaient
échanger selon des instructions qui
figurait dans le coffre contre la
véritable show est en or en sachant que
à l'origine max valentin avait
l'intention de nanterre est qu'une
petite plaque de dix plaques de
plexiglas gravé avec vous et braz et où
on avait gagné téléphoner à tel numéro
entre parenthèses 27 ans après le numéro
est le bon si je n'avais
plus bon donc avec la chouette il ya
quand même un petit mot c'est ce qui l'a
dit j'en sais rien en fait lui seul le
sait puisque personne n'a pu le vérifier
les seuls instructions ont été données
max valentin et heureusement comme
kilian est celle ci c'est que la
chouette étaient enterrés sur un terrain
public il a permis d'éviter quand même
de sa cage et quelques quelques jardins
de voisins pour éviter en effet qu'on
aille sur des propriétés privées donc il
a donné cette information dès la
publication du livre à part cette
information il a rien donné d'autres
évidemment sur le sur le sur le lieu de
la cache
il a donné quelques indications ensuite
prêt mais il est resté assez vague on
comprend pourquoi il ya eu au final
trois éditions du livre sur les traces
de la chouette d'or alors la deuxième
édition comporte exactement les mêmes
éléments que la première avec quelques
traces de changement a priori pas
vraiment importants comme un point
rajouter dans l'énigme 500 ou encore
trois points après le titre de l'énigme
780 oublier à l'origine par typographe
on y trouve également un lot
supplémentaire de 1000 bouteilles de
grands crus ainsi que des photos et des
documents relatifs à michel becker la
troisième édition comportera encore ces
éléments et sera enrichie d'une lettre
supposément signé par un chouette heures
il y aura aussi de nouvelles indications
telles que les localisations négative en
gros ce sont des lieux où la chouette
n'est pas ainsi qu'une interview de max
valentin mais aussi des informations
supplémentaires que les chouettes heurts
ont déjà trouvé depuis très longtemps en
réalité trois éditions car le lancement
de la première édition va avoir un
succès bien au delà des espérances des
auteurs générant d'ailleurs les premiers
problèmes n'avait pas du tout
l'intention d'enterrer d'enterrer un
bronze et ça a permis alors c'est
curieux parce que ça a eu un effet
inattendu c'est qu'en réalité ça a
permis pour l'éditeur et pour régisseur
d'accélérer la publication du bouquin il
voulait sortir ça le plus vite possible
donc la vraie chouette d'or celle ci
était encore en fin de fabrication chez
leur fais où je me rendais régulièrement
à lyon et le bronze qui lui était
terminée a servi à l'éditeur pour faire
une belle vue photoshopée à mort de la
couverture on pense que c'est la
chouette d'or mais en réalité c'est le
premier bon c'est pas celui-là c'est
celui qui enterrait que max valentin a
dû utiliser dans max valentin utilisé la
photo pour la fournir à l'éditeur il est
allé l'intérêt l'éditeur a vite fait son
montage et puis le livre est sorti et je
crois que la chouette d'orge d'une
terminale a terminé elle a dû être
livrés en réalité deux mois après
les médias s'en sont emparés il ya eu
trois éditions on estime qu'il ya eu 70
me de ventes plus de 200 mille
chercheurs à l'époque voilà donc ça
c'est beaucoup de gros chiffres il ya eu
des reportages tes dents voilà sur son
plein de chaînes donc c'est bon c'est
vraiment celle qui a eu cette ampleur
est encore aujourd'hui jusqu'à n'avait
pas encore été trouvé ça tout l'intérêt
de la chose quoi toi tu vis comment tu
dis c'est incroyable qu'ils croyaient
qu'ils auraient ce retentissement là au
départ ou pas j'y croyais sans y croire
vraiment j'ai vraiment fait l'apprenti
sorcier en fait et est comme ça a
démarré curieusement mais bon avec une
certaine logique quand même moi je suis
resté dans mon quotidien et je mettais
un petit peu j'ai laissé la main à max
valentin en me disant c'est l'homme de
communication il va s'occuper de tout ça
quand tu auras des interviews il me dire
ah bah voilà tel jour tu as une
interview j'ai un peu laissé faire c'est
à ce moment là que max valentin va
commencer à changer son rapport à la
chasse ou bien justement à la firme est
la figure emblématique très rapidement
c'est devenu max 90 air max valentin
répondait quotidiennement aux questions
des chercheurs sur le minitel donc
question qui porte à une amende sur les
énigmes sur les visuels sur la
construction la chasse parce que c'était
lui le concepteur de la chasse et des
énigmes c'est vrai qu'en termes de temps
de parole entre 110 milles m'a dit des
yes et versus michel becker non certes
envoyé le visage mais qu'ils n'avaient
pas accès à un petit peu au secret des
dieux le combat était un peu perdue
d'avancé pour voilà donc à gagner pour
ma chouette valentin quand il a subi le
même
ressenti le même effet de surprise que
moi il a été probablement un peu
dépassés par ce qu'ils y arriver parce
qu'il était lui en avait rêvé puisqu'il
avait conçu ces énigmes ces infos je me
trouve un sponsor et quand ça a pris ces
proportions là il est sorti de son rôle
de consultant il avait un petit cabinet
de consulting pour du marketing il était
spécialisé dans la vente la vente par
correspondance on sait pas spécialement
un sexy comme truc est là et il s'est
retrouvé en première ligne mais
paradoxalement nos conventions de départ
d'abord au départ il n'est même pas
signé le livre quand il y avait le
sponsor après il m'a dit bon ben
maintenant que le sponsor s'est retirée
on va mettre nos deux noms moi je vais
mettre un pseudo mais mais au départ il
devait vraiment rester dans l'ombre il
devait pas du tout se faire connaître
donc partis là-dessus il avait tout fait
pour que son anonymat soit respectée et
en même temps il était en première ligne
partout puisque c'est lui qui tenait le
minitel voilà comment est née quelque
chose d'unique et de meetic en faisant
de recherche nous mêmes avions du mal à
nous dire que cette histoire est
contemporaine avant de voir comment je
vous emmène sur les pistes de la chasse
et la construction de ces énigmes parce
que si la chouette est toujours enterré
c'est bien parce que ces deux énigmes
sont uniques en leur genre j'ai 10 12
oui pourtant le livre ne comporte que 11
[Musique]
dans la première partie de ce
documentaire nous sommes restés en 1993
dans cette partie nous allons évoluer de
1993 à 2009 pour comprendre comment les
énigmes sont construites pourquoi cette
chasse à une durée record et surtout
pourquoi la chouette s'est retrouvé
saisie vous allez voir que les dessous
de l'histoire sont aussi dingue que les
énigmes en elle-même
[Musique]
c'est quoi déjà les différentes chasse
au trésor qui existent le principe c'est
toujours le même c'est qu'il doit
enterrer quelque part un trésor et tu
dois pouvoir avec un certain nombre
d'énigmes en nombre limité permettent
d'identifier cet endroit précis la
phrase finale c'est ce qui tu dois
pouvoir la cacher la camoufler dans clés
par exemple dans la chaudière 11 henning
douze énigmes deuxième cacher alors en
plus de ça tu peux rajouter ce qui est
le cas dans la chouette des fausses
pistes parce qu'évidemment si le chemin
est trop clair est trop visible tu vois
tout de suite où on t'emmène et tu peux
même quasiment passés directement la
dernière étape est ce qu'on appelle des
mailles passe donc les façons de de
chanter de passer au delà de ce que le
créateur d'enigma fait et donc le but
c'est de pouvoir justement mettre un
petit peu de flou et un petit peu de
confusion dans tout cela sinon c'est
trop simple trop rapide en général dans
dans une énigme on oppose plusieurs
choses déjà il ya des énigmes on va dire
littéraire comme son nom l'indiqué c'est
c'est des phrases démodé je m'endors au
coucher du soleil exactement la grande
dame de fer pour décrire la tour eiffel
ce que tu veux toi tu peux en effet donc
c'est des choses un petit peu plus voilà
donc littéraire tu as des énigmes plus
visuel donc dans la chouette d'or à
chaque fois qu'il y avait un visuel un
texte qui est la partie de gauche et
donc l'énigme en fait est un titre qui
est l'énigme en fait été la réunion de
ces trois composantes mais tu pourrais
très bien envisager une énigme qui se
fait uniquement sous la forme d'un
dessin qu'on a à la fois des éléments
visuels des éléments de texte et dans le
texte l'on distingue en général de
choses des éléments crypto donc des
petits textes un peu codé avec des
chiffres des efforts des choses comme ça
des petits symboles et puis les choses
plus interprétative comment on peut
camoufler ces éléments dans des énigmes
ces éléments qui sont tellement précis
que si on les voit on les identifie
c'est compliqué justement parce qu'en
plus de cinq ans alors c'est l'élément
littéraire clairement et c'est en
écrivant des phrases qui t'amène d'un
point à un autre le problème de toutes
ces phrases c'est que par définition il
ya des mots qui viennent habiller tout
ça qui n'ont pas de lien direct on va
dire avec avec avec avec l'énigme avec
le propos donc toute la difficulté c'est
d'extraire ce qui va être on va dire du
décorum de façon un peu général que ce
soit dans les visuels ou deux textes et
tout ce qui va être vraiment utile à la
résolution comme est de réussir à mettre
tout ça dans le bon ordre exactement
peut y avoir un sujet d'ordre donc en
fait là dessus il ya des chasses qui
sont linéaires donc tu pars d'une énigme
1 2 tu dois les suivre dans un ordre
bien précis et à des chasses qui sont
plus un peu à la façon d'un puzzle tu
commences un petit peu où tu veux tu
assemble les pièces et un moment le leem
h ce format est ce que tu peux nous
présenter les énigmes de la chouette
dans les grandes ligues coûte on va
commencer déjà par les remettre dans
l'ordre donc la chouette d'or est une
chasse linéaire il faut résoudre les
énigmes dans un certain ordre l'ordre
t'es donné par une énigme donc on va les
regarder ensemble ah oui d'accord c'est
pas l'ordre dans laquelle son moulin
livres et tu comprends dans une énigme
qu'elles ont un art de résolution qui va
te rends tu compte pourquoi toutes les
énigmes donc on quitte chouette ou qui
peut colorer - comme tu peux voir sauf
une c'est henning là tu te rends compte
qu'elle a un petit côté évidemment à
part l apal à petit plein de chouettes
ici est donc cette énigme qui est censé
donc celle qui te donne l'ordre te donne
l'ordre en fait des énigmes un père donc
donne la première la troisième la
cinquième est stable si tu regardes en
fait les chaque énigme une petite est
coloré et un petit chiffre en dessous
oui le petit chiffre en dessous ce sont
des longueurs d'onde hockey des couleurs
bloquée pendant tout coule et ensuite il
faut trouver donc la longueur il faut
trouver les la couleur qui correspond à
la couleur lors des énigmes de chez
matisse 8 et 10 et donc est ce qu'il ya
une cohérence dans l'évolution des
couleurs sur un spectre ou à exactement
si tu regardes sur le visuel tu as tu as
un instant ses rituels exactement donc
là ça quand même pris plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois pour un centre de
chercheurs pour juste trouvé ça donc en
fait il faut que tu te bases sur ce
qu'on appelle un cercle chromatique
donc tu veux en fait toutes les couleurs
du spectre visible on s'en sert en
communication parce qu'on sait très bien
que ça se marie très bien d opposer et
d'un dixième en tête parce que c'est
exactement comme ça que s'est construit
d'accord en fait prendre les couleurs
complémentaires ah ok donc en fait cela
dit si l'on rôles y va sur le rouge
exactement les numéros ne en fait orange
ou la raison de ma terre donc il faudra
trouver l'énigme c'est la seconde map 20
qui correspond en effet don qui est
quelque part ici voilà tu as this thing
rouge rosé et donc en fait tu prends
chaque fois l'énigme père qui donnait
par la couleur complémentaire de
l'énigme ok là on est typiquement sur
une énigme relativement facile oui dans
le sens où quand tu l'as compris tu es
certain de voir qu'il n'ya pas de doute
il ya zéro doute parce que c'est ça la
difficulté pour l'instant des énigmes de
la chouette c'est à chaque fois de se
dire ce que je suis sur la bonne piste
ou pas là cette première henning qui
permet de tout mais dans le bonheur dans
l'été relativement accessible en fait à
deux pas de difficulté ça est-ce que je
suis sur la bonne piste ou pas c'est un
premier point tout à fait valide et c
est ce que j'ai tout résolu
identifiés dans l'énigme tu vois c'est
un peu d'anxiété dans une pièce tu sais
qu'elle est chaude à trouver métier pas
combien parfois tu t'arrêtes pas ce que
tu as l'impression d'avoir trouvé un
élément est en fait ils traitaient de
trois petits éléments encore à trouver
quand je replonge dedans et j'ai failli
faire un peu ça pour la préparation de
cet échange à chaque fois c'est
passionnant tulle et tu lis tu essaies
de dire car ya peut-être une nouvelle
piste la grippe à identifier creusons le
sujet et puis tu tues replonge un peu
comme quelqu'un de comme une addiction
enfin mais clairement il ya une vraie
logique d'addiction comme toute passion
j'ai envie de dire il ya la passion et
puis après il ya le le passage possible
à une obsession qui est qui et qui à ses
fins et clairement il ya des chercheurs
et des shooteurs coin peuvent rien
nature qui ont sacrifié à mon avis des
moments personnels professionnels enfin
on sacrifier des choses parce qu'il
était complètement devenu obsédé par la
chose vous imaginez le jour d'après une
fois qu'on aura trouvé cette chaude
heures pour vous ça va être un grand
vide sérieusement oui je pense que c'est
bien pour les chercheurs que pour mike
valentin ça peut être à granville je
suis pas dire il y avait que ça qu'ils
comptaient mais ça occupait une bonne
partie de mes loisirs de mon temps libre
et ma famille
comment on peut réussir à pointer
précisément un point sur une carte si tu
prends la carte de france qui est
derrière nous donc le principe c'est un
centimètre fait je crois un kilomètre
même par 10 km et ses lois tué région
bêtise ça ne sert à rien millionième
exactement donc tu n'imagines bien que
si tu pointes à un millimètre par
définition ça sera un kilomètre donc la
zone est beaucoup trop grand n'équipe
pas voilà si tu prends les cartes un
petit peu plus détaillée de rendosser
les cartes de rando voilà c'est 1 25000e
donc cette fois un centimètre égal à 250
mètres et donc tout va même une trace de
1 mm ça fait vingt-cinq mètres c'est 25
mètres carrés c'est impossible donc en
fait tu peux pas pointer formellement
sur une carte n'est pas suffisant
l'attenté est en train de remettre en
cause le fantasme de la carte aux
trésors où il ya un grand i sa
et tu dis mais vraiment comment ils
déterrent la trésorerie sur la chouette
d'or se pose la question de savoir est
ce qu'il ya un élément de référence un
arbre un poteau une statue et où on a
envoy après des indications 3 pas vers
le nord les actes avec les sauf que max
valentin indiqué alors là je viens de me
référer un fameux m'a dit un m'a dit où
on m'a dit je t'avouerai que ça jamais
l'académie française s'est pas prononcé
sur le sujet c'est c'est la contraction
de max a dit on estime qu'il ya eu plus
de 110000 à peu près m'a dit donc max a
dit et il y en a près de trente sept
mille qui on est et on va dire
enregistrés qui aujourd'hui sont
disponibles sur internet donc
aujourd'hui à des moteurs de recherche
d'eux m'a dit vous pouvez chercher par
mots clés dans les questions et les
réponses surtout de max valentin tout ça
permet théoriquement
d'affiner d'éliminer de certaines pistes
en disant par exemple est-ce que tel
élément d'un visuel avait son importance
est-ce que telle formulation dans une
phrase était juste
construction à dire littéraire ou est ce
que c'est un élément important pour la
chasse et max valentin devait
normalement un petit peu recentrer un
peu les choses dans ses réponses sur
deux cents ans dix mille questions
réponses possiblement il a pu se tromper
dans peu de temps en temps ils se
contredisent est donc les gens lui vers
leur marque et donc il faut pas non plus
sûr interpréter le problème c'est qu'une
réponse si je vous demande enfin si on
la question qui était posée un exemple a
été tel élément est il important pour la
chasse et qu'ils répondaient de no
coment
ça pourrait vouloir dire beaucoup à la
fois que c'était possiblement
intéressant comme ça n'avait rien à voir
ou qu'ils voulaient juste pas commenter
voilà donc après attention à pas sur
interpréter une réponse ou une absence
de réponse de max valentin et c'est un
peu le risque un petit peu de ces m'a
dit c'est qu'on aille au delà de ce qu'a
voulu juste répondre ou des gens lisent
au deuxième degré par exemple une
réponse au premier degré donc sur ce
média c'est un des m'a dit originaux
exactement il indique qu'il n'y a pas de
construction humaine à 50 mètres à la
ronde donc ce qui veut dire qu'il ya pas
de statut alors ça peut être en effet à
la reconstruction mais donc ça exclut
peut-être d des armes encore une fois
des jeux comme ça mais l'arbre la
difficulté c'est que s'il ya une tempête
et will arnett vie voilà il est obligé
d'avoir un repère pérenne donc toute la
difficulté c'est comment il a pu
indiquer précisément
sans constructions humaines à 50 mètres
donc à une théorique assez intéressante
qui dit que si tu croises est un peu à
la façon de ce qu'on a fait ici avec des
petites cordelette tu prends des repères
assez lointain ah oui et deux repères
mach 4 pers pardon comme ça te donnerai
un emplacement très précis au croisement
par exemple de cordes qui ferait 50 m ou
30 mètres chacune donc on se pose la
question sur la chouette à ce qu'il y a
est-ce qu'il ya un élément un peu comme
ça d'autant plus et on verra après sur
la carte qui a d'être assez intéressant
sur la chouette qui font justement quand
j'ai comme des grands x comme ça je suis
ok c'est passionnant il y a une piste
qui regroupe une bonne partie des
chouettes heures c'est connu on en
reparlera un peu plus en détail c'est la
fameuse piste de tableau dabo c'est un
petit village en moselle qui regroupe
plusieurs éléments qui figurent dans la
chasse est donc en effet il ya une
importante partie des chouettes heures
je suis pas capable de chiffrer mais je
dirais comme celle intuitivement entre
30 et peut-être 50 % qui pensent que la
chouette et à dabo donc c'est un c'est
un village qui n'est pas très grand mais
qui du coup est devenu acquis une vraie
notoriété c'est d'aller à l'office de
tourisme de dabo je vous parlais de la
chouette d'or clairement je pense que
tout le personnel verra de quoi il
s'agit si on met de côté cette piste là
je pense que chaque autres chouettes
heures qui n'est pas sûr d'abord à une
piste qui est quasiment unique alors moi
ça m'amène à parler de la fameuse 12e
énigmes qui serait planquer et les
reliquats est-ce que ça a été trouvée ou
est-ce que ça se cache ça voudrait dire
quoi de les trouver c'est quoi les
enjeux de sark donc dans la chouette
d'or il ya onze énigmes officiel tu
arrives à l'issue des onze énigmes sur
un point précis encore une fois ça fait
une zone d'un kilomètre packard et
peut-être fin c'est beaucoup trop grand
et en fait certains chercheurs se sont
rendu compte en tout cas on soupçonnait
l'existence d'une 12e énigmes et max
valentin dans ces fameux m'a dit a
confirmé en fait c'est tellement là rien
dans les énigmes ne laissait envisager
l'existence d'une deuxième énigme je me
suis dit qu aboutissant sur une zone
assez grande à l'issue de la 11e le
chercheur le plus avancé or à l'idée de
revenir en arrière vérifiez qui n'a rien
oublié rien n'était écrit dans le livre
pour concernant cette 12e mais des gens
l'ont subodorer en fait en échangeant un
petit peu avec madjo lantin et il a
confirmé effectivement l'existence donc
aujourd'hui ce que nous ne sais pas
c'est à quoi elle ressemble parce
qu'elle est littéraire parce qu'elle est
graphique toile extrême tu pourrais dire
on peut couper des visuels le former des
choses qui ressembleraient à des
éléments de terrain priori on sait que
c'est pas ça aujourd'hui les fameux
reliquat dont parlait ce sont des
éléments qui la composent est ce que ces
reliquats sont des chiffres est ce que t
as vu qu'elles sont des lettres des mots
et comment tout ça se combinent est-ce
que ça forme une phrase encore une fois
ne pas et aujourd'hui mais il n'y a
absolument pas de certitudes là dessus
voilà enfin il ya personne qui a acquis
à identifier de manière
évidente à la belle exactement ce que ce
que peuvent être les reliquats
paraissent qu'il est trop tôt à ce que
parce que c'est parce que les gens sont
pas assez avancée dans la résolution
c'est quelque chose qui te saute un peu
aux yeux quand arriva le 11e nuit
l'appel passé à d'ailleurs une douzième
henning parce que c'est pas formellement
une énigme uni mail à un énoncé affaire
trouve a tué quelque chose qu ils
appellent ça la super solution donc
c'est à dire tu reprends un petit peu
des solutions que prend des éléments qui
ont servi mais qui ne sont pas la
solution finale des énigmes mon espèce
de point d'étape peut-être d'où le mot
reliquat voilà les choses que tu as mis
un petit peu de côté exactement et puis
tu composes tout ça alors doit y avoir
une cohérence entre s'imaginent que
c'est pas mettre des choux et des
carottes voilà faut trouver un peu de
logique mais c'est ça qui est surprenant
c'est de te dire que tu n'as pas voilà
les gens n'ont pas croisé suffisamment
de ces éléments est encore une fois fort
contient un endroit précis donc si c'est
une phrase par exemple ça nécessite au
moins quinze ou vingt mètres tu vois
quelque chose pour te dire à 3 m le
grand chêne 23 quelque chose comme ça
passionnant aussi de se dire ok donc
qu'il a pu en fait c'est précis ni clé
de sécurité c'est à dire celui qui
trouve trouve vraiment parce qu'ils
avaient déjà tous à ce moment là et que
je lui donne le dernier truc pour la
précision en fait alors moi j'ai une
théorie là-dessus mais que je peux de
partager mais c'est ce que doit il doit
avoir verrouillé les choses justement il
a dû vraiment faire un truc un peu
malins qui nécessitait que tu es tout
résolu ouais et donc possiblement les
reliquats sont issus moi je pense
peut-être des villes par lesquels tu vas
pas céder
des trajets que tu vas faire sur ta
carte comme ça tu es certain qu'il faut
avoir fait des actes eux mans le mon
trajet dans le bon ordre et que si tu te
plantes un moment qu'il fait partie n'a
pas tout c'est une possibilité toit
s'est passé dans le foie il ya zéro
certitude faut être très humble au
sensationnel à une douzième énigmes qui
se dévoilerait au moment où on trouve la
réponse aux onze énigmes précédente ça
c'est dingue des reliquats qui existent
justement pour créer et résoudre cette
deuxième énigme les énigmes de cette
chasse ont aussi imbriqué que les rêves
du film inception mais est ce la seule
difficulté des énigmes qui rendent cette
chasse aussi longue non il ya une autre
explication
alors ben on a évoqué mascarade donc été
un peu la référence dont elle est la
nourais peu près trois ans donc c'était
un petit peu la première chasse
d'ampleur en angleterre si on évoque une
autre chasse d'ampleur fait par man ray
lantin qui était 13h dorval qui avait un
globe d'une valeur de 200 mille euros
elle a duré un an et demi on a des
chasses qui ont durant général de prénom
le premier a duré un an la deuxième un
petit peu moins si je devais faire un
peu loin de tout ça je dirais c'est
entre 1 an et 3 4 ans voilà je crois que
max valentin lui-même avait estimé la
chasse à leur estime et je suis pas
comme il avait pu estimer cela mais
entre on va dire 18 et 24 mois
c'est très compliqué c'est très
compliqué c'est même quasiment
impossible parce qu'en fait c'est ça
oblige à se mettre dans l'esprit de tous
les chercheurs potentiel donc après la
question se pose mais c'est plus un
élément de construction de chasser des
verrous faire des éléments vraiment tant
qu'on n'a pas débloqué cet élément là il
ya une espèce de point de blocage dans
la chasse votre question c'est ça c'est
plus une question de où est ce que je me
mets verrons à quel endroit un petit peu
la construction la chasse à ce que
j'aime et très tôt pas trop combien j'en
ai donc c'est un petit peu comme ça que
les chalets et les parents les créateurs
de chasse peuvent plus ou moins
verrouillé pourquoi
on commence à donner des yes yes pour
dire un petit peu de quoi il s'agit une
c'est une indication supplémentaire donc
l'indication supplémentaire c'est
l'auteur d'une chasse d'eau trésor peut
en fait communiquer alors sur son site
web par voie de communiqué parce que peu
importe de des indications qui
permettent un peu débloquer la chasse
donc max valentin a publié un certain 10
aces d'indications supplémentaires entre
93 et 96 dont pendant les trois
premières années à peu près de la chasse
de la chasse il ya un élément important
c'est que beaucoup de gens se sont
interrogés pourquoi max valentin vais
arrêter public et de publier des billets
196 il a vu que la chasse quand même
n'était pas trouvée par définition au
bout de 5 ans 10 ans beaucoup de gens
sont dit mais il pourrait peut-être
donner un petit indice aujourd'hui et il
l'a pas fait alors il a toujours
considéré qu'il avait donné un petit peu
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient s'en ensuite
biaisé trop le jeu évidemment le but
c'était pas qu'après unis est où se
trouvait en 24 heures et que les gens
déboulent dans une forêt avec des pelles
pioches et que ça se finisse de toute
façon un peu violente l'analyse pour moi
des dernières pièces peut donner
quelques informations parce qu'il a dû
donner un peu plus dans les derniers en
effet pour essayer de déverrouiller sans
pour autant évidemment tout donner sur
un plateau parce que c'est passé pas
loin
[Musique]
un max valentin reconnu l'existence de
fausses pistes donc ça c'est certain il
a même été un petit peu plus loin dans
son analyse il a évoqué une fausse piste
autoroutière c'est à dire en dix ans il
a pris une analogie enfin il est dit
voilà c'est un peu comme si vous
avanciez sur une autoroute il ya une
petite bretelle de sortie et tout le
monde continue à fond sur l'autoroute
donc sur la fausse piste et oublier un
petit peu de sortir sur la véritable
solution qui était une petite bretelles
d'une quitte une petite bretelle de
sortie que que les gens lui prendre
chaque chercheur chaque chouette heures
va développer sa propre théorie arrivé à
un point je pense qu'il ya quasiment
jamais deux fois la même la même piste
versez une spécificité de chasse assez
incroyable donc chacun développe en fait
à partir d'un même livre des mêmes
énigmes des théories complètement
différente et ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est très spécifique à la
chouette aujourd'hui quand lui parler un
petit peu de la fin quand il parlait
comme de son vivant est une enfant de la
durée record de sa chasse max valentin a
expliqué s'il devait changer une chose
aujourd'hui dans la chouette d'or c'est
qu'il ne mettrait pas autant de fautes
de fausses pistes parce qu'il se rend
compte que justement les chercheurs
secret ces fausses pistes de même et qui
a absolument pas besoin d'en rajouter
après des coïncidences il y en a
énormément c'est vrai que c'est très
impressionnant quand on est un petit peu
les forums et les solutions des uns des
autres
mais c'est toute la complexité et c'est
encore plus renforcée à l'heure
d'internet et d'outils comme wikipedia
qui avec des éléments historiques des
dates dès qu'on peut trouver des
corrélations entre tous
[Musique]
le fameux bug de mongkok ouais rien à
trouver dedans il va pas d'un côté sur
cherbourg et de l'autre côté ailleurs si
tu continues est un qui peut les tracés
du coq sur la console sur la carte de
france ouais tu te rends compte qu'en
fait les arrivées sur certaines villes
et c'était pas des villes anodine parce
que c'est des villes qui servait dans le
cadre
des autres énigmes ah oui d'accord qu'on
retrouvait plus exactement dans la shoah
notamment cherbourg on se vouvoie là et
donc cesser a priori ça fait pas partie
de ce que max valentin demandé à michel
becker de faire et donc se pose aussi
une question de ça c est ce que cette
fameuse tête de coq le les formes du bec
et c est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
était une énorme intuition michel becker
coup de chance incroyable voilà
coïncidence on ne sait pas en réalité
moi j'ai peint d'une façon très
spontanée et après coup les chercheurs
ont commencé à poser des questions sur
le minitel à un max valentin qui s'était
fait un devoir de répondre d'une manière
sybilline laissant à penser en fait aux
chercheurs qu'à un moment donné il y
avait des trucs à trouver dans le bec du
coq dans le personnage sous
l'arc-en-ciel ou des choses comme ça
alors que tout était alors que moi je
n'avais aucun élément c'était purement
mon imaginaire où ma gestuelle parce que
quand on peint on voit là mais alors où
ça devient un peu vicelard c'est que
effectivement on peut quand même
envisager que malgré tout le bec de
mongkok pointe quand même sur cherbourg
d'un côté sur roncevaux de l'autre et
que comme par hasard c'est des points
qui ont une existence dans le trajet de
trajet des énigmes donc il ya des
coïncidences comme ça mais je pense qu'à
certains moments
max valentin assure fait un peu là
dessus on a rajouté et probablement à
générer des
fausses pistes en fait à tour de bras
avec avec des visuels qui sont quand
même c'est complexe la publication du
fameux cahier des charges pour michel
becker en décembre 2019 récemment a
permis de recentrer un peu le débat là
dessus et on s'est rendu compte
finalement il est assez peu de choses
dans un visuel pour chaque visuel à peu
près ça c'est reposait sur un deux trois
éléments maximum donc c'était une ligne
en général de deux cahiers des charges
donc ces visuels sont à la fois
important pour la résolution mais on
sait aujourd'hui qu'il ya pas non plus
des informations critiques de nombreux
dons clairement le texte je pensais à
une importance bout enfin voilà c'est
plus primordiale et évidemment que que
les visuels pas aujourd'hui le cahier
des charges formelles et rédigé dont on
dispose indique un coq avec ses pattes
sur gauche ce qui illustre quelque part
que entre le cahier des charges et sonic
qu'il ya eu et il y avoir derrière il ya
la république quelques éléments dont
disposent pas max valentin donc le
créateur des énigmes indiqué que
certaines fausses pistes étaient assez
élégante et en fait se continuer sur
plusieurs énigmes et c'est là que ça
devient compliqué c'est que tu pars sur
une fausse piste mais à ce moment là
tout seul je ne sais pas et tu arrives à
une autre énigme où tu as des éléments
koussa rentrent en résonance quand même
exactement telle confirmation tu dis ah
ben tiens ça ça suive ya une suite
logique et ça peut continuer sur
plusieurs énigmes et c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué si t'as pas t'as pas un
élément un sens interdit aux gens qui te
dit ce que disait max valentin c'est s
et es tu devrais arriver à un moment une
espèce de voie sans issue et une avance
plus et donc de à partir de là à faire
le constat que tu habites n'était pas la
bonne
plate approche de la fin tu dois
chercher des sentinelles il faut les
passer en revue donc là beaucoup de gens
interprètent ça à mon sens est erronée
mais encore une fois faut être
extrêmement rare mais là dessus comme il
va falloir trouver trois éléments et
creuser un peu au milieu c'est vrai que
la piste de dabola dessus en fait tu
trouves trois blocs de pierre qui sont
assez proches et les gens qui sont
persuadés en fait ils sont à la bonne
distance parce que tu vois tu dois faire
ça à 8000 mesure pour les partisans de
la piste de dabo c'est une certitude que
si la confirmation d'autant plus qu'un
certain nombre de ces rochers ont des
dates en fait qu'y figure dessus et
qu'on retrouve un peu à la dernière j'ai
un petit ami un petit livre pour te
montrer un peu le les fausses pistes les
consignes en tant que ça au pays de dabo
exactement alors donc si tu regardes en
fait il ya deux dates qui sont
mentionnés dedans
1727 1750 et alors si tu regardes la
première partie ça te fait 1727 mais pas
dans même pas tant pas dans le bon sens
et le 1750 à les deux dates mais tu vois
qu'ils figurent un peu dans de façon un
peu
dans le désordre est alors regarde la
petite citation également qu
intéressante ça c'est un petit manuel de
kiel à 2,92 la sentinelle des deux
autres en fait ils en parlent comme si
c'était des professionnels dans ce
bouquin c'est c'est enfin directement
quasiment livre est sorti en 92 donc
sachant que malgré l'entente avait écrit
ses énigmes dont 78 se pose la question
parce que à l'époque savaient déjà cette
appellation à ce que la personne qui
écrit ce bouquin là c'est inspiré le
même d'un autre tout notre source
documentaire voilà fort de sa beaucoup
de gens se sont dit que finalement la
piste dabo qui était un peu trop belle
pour être vraie parce qu'elle revenait
régulièrement et est cette fameuse
fausse piste autoroutière donc là dessus
il ya un vrai débat en tant de fois
entre les dabistes ce qu'on appelle
c'est à dire les fervents de la théorie
de la banque considère que comme d'abord
revient plusieurs fois dans la chouette
c'est ça ne peut être que la seule la
bonne solution et ce king considère
justement al'inverse que c'est la
fameuse fausse piste
autoroutière qu'il ne faut pas emprunter
du cou et autour et qu'il faut peut-être
emprunter un moment mais de laquelle il
va falloir sortir comme la chouette
nature n'a été trouvé au bout de 28
cents moi je serais plutôt partisan de
me dire que alors dabo peut intervenir
au tout début mais qu'après tout le
reste ça n'est qu'une construction ça
une fausse piste
car après ce qui est intéressant mais
c'est là où toi tu rentres dans la façon
dont une chasse doit être construite
c'est comment tu fais continuer la piste
dabo sur deux trois énigmes en l'ayant
mise au début de manière légitime on va
dire et comment tu peux trouver une
piste alternative en ayant les mêmes
phrases en fait tu vois c'est toute la
difficulté c'est qu'avec une même énigme
tu dois avoir la fausse piste
est la véritable qui est caché un petit
peu au même endroit dans les choses
intéressantes il est originaire
de la moselle est de la france
il se trouve que dabo et ans et en
moselle également dans les déjà france
et c'est vrai que et puis les tracés un
petit peu qui figure sur dans la
chouette d'or pourrait amener un petit
peu dans ce coin là donc c'est vrai que
l'est de la france à une afin retient
une attention particulière pour pas mal
de deux chercheurs de chouettes qu'il
soit d'abord is to pas de gaullistes
beaucoup de gens qui pensent que ce
serait possiblement dans ce coin-là coin
qui a connu dans son enfant soit
un faux nom un moyen de communication à
la fois privilégié mais à la fois isolé
du reste du monde à savoir détenu par
une seule et même personne un langage un
peu secret quasi mystique d'une
communauté qui porte un nom max valentin
avec consciemment ou inconsciemment
réunit tous les éléments pour créer une
aura particulière autour de sa personne
aya clairement à valence est devenu une
espèce de figure
où tout le monde fantasmé sur son
identité ça pouvait être c'était très
très drôle c'est quand tu rencontré
quelqu'un d'un peu érudit qui peut avoir
peut-être un tic de langage de
l'impression c'est
ton profonde à tafas ssl sa peau max
valentin pour être à peu près n'importe
quoi il est devenu en quelque sorte un
deus ex machina puisque personne ne
connaissait son identité les journaux
l'interviewait alors il se présentait un
coup en passe montagne un coup masquer
un coup dans des trucs pas possibles
dans l'ombre tout ce qu'on voulait mais
en même temps ça lui a donné une
dimension
de gourou un peu par rapport à tous ces
chercheurs qui tous les jours venaient
yb rhonelle minitel parce que parce
qu'il voulait il voulait parler de leur
solution de leurs idées et puis lui
s'est pris au jeu et c'est devenu un peu
le grand prêtre de cette chasse système
un peu de questions réponses a entretenu
sa serre ça a laissé derrière des écrits
qui sont un peu ouais c'est ça c'est
presque parole d'évangile derrière c'est
devenu on analysait un peu les paroles
du prophète exactement c'est ça et de
fil en aiguille il en est il a perdu un
petit peu la notion de ce qui avait été
le les accords de départ et puis je dire
l éthique de départ de cette chasse et
puis il en a fait une chaire chez en
tout cas sans faire une chasse personnel
il s'est créé un personnage virtuel
avant midi tél avant internet je veux
dire déjà sur minitel il avait un
personnage virtuel ce qui était pas
très fréquent quand même à l'époque
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué de se
créer une identité virtuelle lui avait
réussi à le faire et donc avec sa belle
son identité virtuelle lui a permis de
faire un peu tout et n'importe quoi il a
un peu oublié les les règles de qu'on
avait défini etc il a donc embarqué
cette histoire à sa manière y compris
sur les milliers de commentaires qu'il a
faits sur mes tableaux et se verra donc
sa embarquer beaucoup de gens dans des
directions que j'aurais pas soupçonner
en fait des gens qui ont vraiment vécu
avec la chouette et d'antoine valentin
comme
compagnon de vie quelque part de route
donc non qu' il ya clairement
un lien fort qui a pu se créer avec ces
gens là mais c'est là que le sort frappe
alors que personne ne s'y attend la
chouette risque de s'envoler loin de
tout le monde pourquoi comment pour une
question purement légale et pragmatique
la chouette d'or donc à l'époque était
détenu par la maison d'édition qui
devait remettre donc le lot au gagnant
de la chasse lors de la faillite de la
dernière maison d'édition maison
d'édition de publier plein d'autres
livres le liquidateur judiciaire delà de
la maison d'édition en question a été
saisir tous les actifs tous les biens
détenus par la maison d'édition pour les
vendre et payer les créanciers sur la
procédure et est en fait est là si l'on
saisit la chouette d'or non mais voilà
ça appartient à la maison d'édition max
valentin s'est rendu compte de ça il a
essayé de faire des procédures pour
essayer de récupérer la chouette d'or il
en a pas forcément parler de suite à
michel beckers qui il a un petit peu
énervé on peut le comprendre ensuite
donc c'est un petit peu encore plus
crispé je pense les relations et donc
ensuite des procédures judiciaires ont
permis à martin et michel becker de
récupérer la chouette d'or qui avaient
été saisis saisie par huissier ça a pris
quand même facilement 3 3 4 ans dans
lequel il une espèce d'incertitudes sur
le s que la chouette d'or du coup
resterai toujours le lot où est-ce
qu'elle serait saisie par le liquidateur
judiciaire de la maison d'édition suite
à ça la chouette d'or a été remise suite
à la décision du tribunal la cour
d'appel de versailles à michel becker
puisqu'il était le propriétaire mais
elle a bien précisé jusqu'à la
découverte de la chouette par une
éventuelle chercher un nom qu'il ya une
décision juridique qui mentionne à la
fois la propriété michel becker mais
également que
c'est en attendant évidemment un
éventuel découvreurs c'est alors que le
pire des drames arrivent dans la nuit du
23 au 24 avril 2009 régis other alias
max valentin décède brutalement les
étapes de création des énigmes les
solutions les explications de chaque
pourquoi et de chaque comment de cette
chasse aux trésors disparaissent avec
lui quelles ont été les conséquences de
son décès assez inattendu dans la
troisième et dernière partie vous allez
découvrir ce qu'il s'est passé et où
nous en sommes à ce jour
[Musique]
donc les solutions
théoriquement aujourd'hui ne sont connus
par personne
elles ont été rédigées par max valentin
mise dans cette enveloppe scellée par
max valentin donc avec ces fameux caché
à la cire est remise à lui sied les
héritiers de max valentin ont été voir
l'huissier pour vérifier l'existence de
cette enveloppe maintenant cette
enveloppe à chamouille été ouverte donc
possiblement un peu évident ouah ça
serait peu probable encore une fois mais
bon c et puis après on ne sait pas ce
qu'il ya écrit dessus évidemment quoi
voilà cette chouette d'or c'est quand
même pas forcément un cadeau pour les
héritiers de michael en train qui ont
clairement mérité sa
part définition malgré eux et qui pour
eux aujourd'hui ne nous apporte plutôt
que d en tout des problèmes et doivent
gérer des chercheurs frustré qui se
demandent est-ce que les solutions
existent ou pas doivent gérer la
relation avec michel becker voilà ils
ont plus dans merde à gérer pour à peu
près aucun bénéfice il ya eu des propos
des écrits même
de quelqu'un qui est décédé il ya pas
très longtemps qu'il y avait donc comme
pseudo fils 2002 qui a travaillé avec
max valentin et qui lui m'a dit un jour
au téléphone mais moi je sais très bien
où les chercheurs font fausse route je
sais à quel moment et ils sortent de la
voie royale et c'est donc a priori il
avait il détenait lui un certain nombre
d'éléments qui lui permettait
d'apprécier un petit peu je pense pas
qu'ils connaissaient les solutions quant
aux héritiers ça c'est pour l'instant
c'est un mystère est ce qu'ils les ont
regardés est-ce qu'ils ont regardé des
notes parce qu'il doit y avoir quand
même pas mal de documents avec est le
fils de kim avait d'ailleurs dit que le
livre des solutions étaient prêts qu'ils
étaient déjà rédigé donc il n'y a pas
que l' enveloppe des solutions ah oui
pour une publication éventuelle voilà
voilà voilà voilà oui d'accord donc ces
éléments là existe et il est probable
que les héritiers à un moment donné les
ont vus en main après qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont regardé pas regarder
c'est le mystère de la chouette d'or
lorsque le payer les charges a été
publié par michel becker en décembre
2019 il s'est avéré qu'une version
pirate bay cahier des charges a été
communiquée sur internet en octobre 2019
de trois mois avant
ce qui sous-entendrait que des gens
avaient eu accès à ce qui est des
charges avant
la question c'est qui comment est-ce que
c'est michel becker qui l'a transmis à
certaines personnes pour des raisons que
l'on ignore est-ce que c'est des gens
qui l'ont volé à michel becker est ce
que voilà donc toutes ces questions font
que les chercheurs sont très très très
prudent sur le fait que certaines
personnes puissent avoir accès aux
solutions pour éviter que se reproduise
ce même genre de désagrément le riz
c'est toute personne qui a pu avoir
connaissance de ces solutions est un
risque potentiel sur le fait un risque
de fuite tout simplement quand est-ce
que l'association à 2 0 la 2 c'est opter
l'association des chercheurs de chouette
d'or où tous les ans ils forment ce
qu'on a vu une chouette fait qu'un truc
très sympa qui s'organise dans des
villes qui ont un lien avec la chouette
olatz de ce côté un peu ludique et léger
las de ces eaux intervient en justice
pour pérenniser en fait la chouette d'or
eux ils ont des idées des demandes assez
simple c'est vis-à-vis de la famille
s'assurer que les solutions sont bien
protégés et vis-à-vis de michel becker
s'assurer que michel becker remettra
bien le lots aux gagnants voilà c'est un
peu l'heure de demande qui me semble à
moi assez légitime cette association a
été générée voulu initier par max
valentin et quelques proches à l'époque
où le minitel s'est arrêté donc à
l'époque il avait commencé à reprendre
la main sur l'opération il a mis en tête
de tout le monde qu'il fallait surtout
pas surtout pas à montrer des solutions
à l'échelle becker parce qu'il allait
dévoiler toute la foire et le jeu ce qui
est totalement faux puisque je suis l'un
des seuls à avoir essayé de sauver le
jeu au moment de son décès mais enfin
peu importe il avait mis cette idée là
donc dans la tête des chercheurs et en
plus moi je communiquais pas beaucoup
donc ils se sont fait à cette idée et
puis le jour de son décès j'ai quand
même un peu dit ce que je pensais quoi
qu'il s'était passé des choses un peu
bizarre notamment la saisie de la
chouette le fait que sa mère était
dissimulé ses terrains et à ce moment là
les chercheurs se sont dits bombe à lui
il dit du mal de max valentin il est en
colère c'est un traître et c'est donc
ouais ouais j'ai cette image à cette
image là apij monde je l'aurais toujours
elle va me collait à la peau pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux après le
décès de magra lantin michel becker
prétextant le fait qu'il ne pouvait pas
certifier
le fait qu'ils aient le choix est
enterré et que les séries de solution
n'aurait pas circuler a voulu arrêter la
chasse s'est fait plein de façons il a
écrit aux héritiers de max valentin et
puis un jour a été jusqu'à mettre la
chouette en vente à drouot donc là les
chouettes heures se sont organisés ont
écrit à au commissaire priseur ont fait
une action en justice même pour montrer
qu'en effet il y avait un jugement qui
indiquait que certes michel becker était
propriétaire de la chouette mais qu'il
devait la livre et le jour où elle était
trouvé donc à ce titre vous pouvez pas
forcer ne pouvait pas la vendre voilà
donc mais c'est vrai que voilà ce s'est
posé cette question de pourquoi michel
becker et voulu la mettre en vente
aujourd'hui ce qui réécrit l'histoire ou
est-ce que c'était la réalité
aujourd'hui il indique que c'était pour
mettre un peu un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière pour faire bouger un petit
peu les héritiers de max valentin
voilà pour provoquer un petit peu les
discussions très clairement la chute
n'est plus aujourd'hui la seule
motivation de cette chasse la légende a
pris largement le dessus et le gain
financier n'est plus le seul moteur la
chouette d'or c'est devenu un symbole
qui est donc par définition inestimable
mais nous devons aborder des questions
essentielles la chouette est elle encore
enterré est-ce qu'on peut la récupérer
quels sont les grands axes de résolution
conduit à ce jour les nouveaux joueurs
bénéficient clairement de tout le
travail qui a été fait en allemand par
part par les anciens entre guillemets
donc ça c'est plutôt bénéfique pour eux
mais on se rend compte aujourd'hui qu'il
ya des nouvelles générations des gens
qui découvrent ce cette chasse et c'est
ça qui est rigolo justement et qui s'y
met avec un regard neuf et kiki qui
prennent un petit peu le relais d'autres
personnes qui a abandonné depuis
maintenant faut avoir un regard critique
pour pouvoir justement de bien
appréhender et bien trier un petit peu
le bon grain de l'ivraie sur sur les ses
solutions et ça c'est quelque chose je
pense qu elle plus complexe qui est le
moins
un indien enfin et que le défaut
principal des chouettes heures si je
devais en nommer un c'est cette absence
de regard critique et de recul sur les
solutions des autres et surtout sur ses
solutions et du coup de ton ressenti
parce que je sais qu'on est sûr de rien
est ce que tu penses que cette chouette
et enterrait encore au moment où on
parle c'est la question la plus délicate
ça c'est la plus délicate on sait qu'à
l'époque où la chouette a été saisie du
fait de la faillite d'une des sociétés
d'édition dans lesquels ré max valentin
était associé une idée qui circule est
de dire qu'il aurait pu pendant cette
période où il achète indépendant voilà
était entre les mains d'un liquidateur
il n'était pas sur la récupérer il
aurait pu décider déterrer la
contremarque en se disant au moins
pendant ce temps là personne n'a trouvé
je risque pas d'être coincé avec ce à
quoi en se disant je vais aller les
remettre après la seul truc c'est quand
le procès s'est terminé bien il est mort
trois mois après quoi des hypothèses
après il a prétendu être retourné sur
place avoir sorti la chouette de sa
cachette pour refaire l'emballage en
disant qu'il n'avait pas ramené chez lui
mais qu'il avait fait sur place d'aucuns
prétendent qu'il l'a ramené chez lui on
sort jamais enfin pour l'instant on peut
pas savoir on saura sûrement mais pour
l'instant on sait pas et on sera
peut-être pas avant longtemps j'en sais
rien la chouette d'or existe c'est une
certitude est ce qu'il y à la fameuse
copier en bronze qui est censé être
entente est enterré et qui serait
échanger contre la chouette d'or ça
personne ne peut le dire si demain moi
je trouve la chouette je peux pas
forcément faire l'échangent contre cette
chouette la légalement situe maintenant
que le deuxième bronze pas celui-là
ouais ouais si tu m'apportes le deuxième
bond blood stone l'a choqué mais ça si
si il faut fait ça c'est une volonté de
toi ce que je veux dire c'est que
légalement je pense qu'il ya plus rien
qui obligea les parce que là la chaleur
existants expliqué il ya d'ailleurs
actuellement il ya une procédure en
cours intenté par un chercheur qui nous
fait procédure sur procédure
souhaite quand même que soit vérifié la
cache c'est un élément sur lequel il est
possible qu'ils obtiennent gain de cause
parce que finalement en dehors de max
valentin personne n'a jamais ni vu
l'endroit ni assisté à l'enfouissement
de la contremarque on n'a aucune
certitude le sol qui pouvait avoir des
certitudes et qui aurait pu donner des
éléments de preuve il est décédé donc
voilà je les écris d'ailleurs dans le
dos là de la dernière édition je ne peux
en aucun cas garantir la présence de la
contremarque sa place j'en sais rien
honnêtement j'en sais rien 95% ou
peut-être même plus encore des
chercheurs sont plus du tout là pour la
chouette d'or enfin pas en tout cas plus
pour le pour le montant par monter le
l'élément pécunier en effet ils sont là
pour arrêter celui qui a résolu cette
énigme un peu mythique donc je pense que
pour beaucoup la chouette en bon talent
largement la même valeur que que les
chatons c'est le véritable trésor c'est
celui qui est enterré qui est sous terre
depuis 28 ans et qui est vraiment
mythique en effet et qui la récompense
de celui qui aurait été plus malin que
les autres pour pour la trouver et l'a
clairement vers la chouette de bronze à
la une histoire qui est quand même en
effet conséquente depuis depuis ses 28
ans
[Musique]
on a vraiment des informations de
dernière minute comme vous le savez ça
fait un an qu'on a travaillé sur ce
projet et continuelle et qu on le
peaufine on s'apprête à sortir denis
était en train d'exporter la bdf quand
on a eu de nouvelles informations de
nouveaux rebondissements
je suis obligé de faire cet ajout pour
vous en parler le 30 octobre 2021 sur la
chaîne youtube les éditions de la
chouette d'or michel becker a publié une
vidéo une vidéo courte mais où il parle
de plein de choses qui sont très
troublantes et qui rajoute encore de
nouvelles questions à cette chasse mig
on y apprend tout d'abord que michel
becker aurait signé un accord avec les
héritiers de max valentin et de suite à
cet accord il aurait eu accès à toutes
les solutions donc il en parle lui-même
ouvertement il dit d'ailleurs que
l'ultime solution la super solution de
l'emplacement au centimètre près de la
cache donc ça veut dire que michel
becker à partir de ce moment-là connaît
la cache de la chouette d'or de la
contremarque en bronze est bien plus que
ça il explique qu'il y est allé en
présence d'un huissier
on ne connaît pas encore l'huissier on
sait pas s'il y avait d'autres personnes
ou pas qui étaient présentes aussi bien
la lecture des supers solutions et des
solutions de la chouette que le jour où
ils ont été déterrés la contremarque
mais en tout cas c'est sûr michel becker
s'est rendu sur place et a été vérifié
que la contremarque était toujours
présente il nous explique toujours dans
cette vidéo là que c'était pas la
chouette en bronze qui étaient enterrés
mais un oiseau de métal on n'en sait pas
plus qui se serait abîmé avec le temps
alors comment cette fois zoo s'est
retrouvé là est ce que c max valentin
qui avait effectivement déterrer la
contremarque et qu'il l'avait remplacé
parce qu'il voulait la remettre à plus
tard la question que moi je me pose là
c'est très personnel c'est ou et le la
chouette en bronze original et michel
becker explique aussi qu'il a remplacé
du coup le set oiseaux un petit peu
abîmés en métal par une vraie chouette
en bronze comme c'était prévu donc est
ce qu il a fait un autre jour parce que
j'imagine qu'ils n'en avaient pas une
sur lui sous le bras pour le maître donc
est ce qu'il y aller deux fois il ya
beaucoup de questions comme ça qui
commence à naître juste suite à cette
déclaration une autre question là aussi
c'est personnel que je me pose c'est
est-ce que c'est oiseaux qui étaient
enterrés on peut le voir quelque part
est ce qu'on le découvrira je sais que
moi si je cherchais la chouette d'or
mais en fait c'est cette photo là que
j'aimerais avoir c'est celui qui a
enterré depuis le plus longtemps et puis
en creusant un petit peu on s'aperçoit
que la chouette est en train de vivre
des changements par exemple michel
becker a changé beaucoup d'éléments du
règlement de la chouette d'or alors je
pense qu'il a le droit de le faire
légalement mais c'était pas si visible
c'est vraiment en comparant qu'on s'est
rendu compte de ça donc c'est important
aussi de le savoir on s'aperçoit aussi
que sur le site des éditions de la
chouette d'or maintenant il ya des des
copies de la chouette en bronze qui soit
avant dont je crois d'une pas d'une
valeur de 15 mille euros environ donc on
peut avoir sa propre show dort chez soi
bref on voit que c'est en train de
reprendre une vie un peu différente
soulevant de nouvelles questions sur
combien de personnes du coup on lui
accès aux solutions à ce que michel
becker même sans le vouloir parfois ça
aurait pas susceptible de donner des
indices combien de personnes ont pu
accéder à cette cache là où est cet
oiseau qui a été déterrée où est la
contremarque du cou qui étaient là avant
qu est ce qu on a fait max valentin moi
j'ai presque envie de dire c'est presque
une nouvelle chasse j'ai envie de
chasser en fait la première contre
marque et l'a trouvé bref c'était un
petit ajout des dernières minutes pour
vous donner les infos les plus fraîches
mais aussi pour vous dire que même après
un aussi gros documentaire qui demandait
au temps de travail eh bien on se rend
compte que l'histoire est loin d'être
finie
je remercie énormément toute mon équipe
qui a travaillé sur cette vidéo en
particulier jérémy loïc fanny et denis
merci également à michel becker et à
gênés alvarez qui m'ont permis d'accéder
à des informations et à des lieux
inédits et surtout leurs connaissances
et leur implication dans la vie de la
chouette d'or ont été très très précieux
pour faire ce documentaire tous les deux
d'ailleurs sont impliqués eux aussi dans
une nouvelle chasse michel becker
récidive avec un nouveau projet
ambitieux une nouvelle chasse qu'il
l'est tout autant julien alvarez lui
fait partie des éditions du trésor et si
ce nom vous dit quelque chose c'est pas
pour rien c'est parce que j'ai créé avec
eux une chasse en 2018 et je vous
faisais gagné 10 véritable diamant les
éditions du 13 heures reviennent avec
une nouvelle chasse que j'ai pu
découvrir et qui s'annonce vraiment
folle elle a déjà commencé c'est lors de
sipan et enfin merci énormément domaine
de la pierre ronde qui nous accueille
pour ce tournage dans ce décor
incroyable ce décor naturel en du moins
qu'ils ont créée c'est un village
fantastique vous pouvez venir séjourner
et dormir dans une maison de hobbits une
maison de magicien un tipi une yourte
qui voulaient déconnecter en pleine
nature dans un lieu insolite et un peu
incroyable vous allez trouver le lien
vers leur site dans la description avec
les liens vers la chasse de l'ordre de 6
panne et la chasse du trésor de
l'entente cordiale
bref vous avez tous dans la description
j'espère que ce nouveau format sur la
chaîne vous a plu c'est un travail de
plus d'un an que vous venez de voir se
concrétiser nous on a hâte de lire vos
avis vos retours dans les commentaires
sur ce genre de vidéos qui essaient pour
une fois d'aller plus loin au coeur d'un
sujet d'où la longueur de la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à liker la partager bien
sûr à vous abonner la chaîne approche 2
millions d'abonnés ça c'est grâce à vous
c'est fou merci et comme toujours ici
vous trouverez deux autres vidéos ces
deux autres vidéos sur les cabinets
curieuse vidéo plus rapide ici une vidéo
sur l'île de pâques avec aq ce lot est
ici une vidéo sur l'île de la rose avec
toi sont les coûts prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt ciao loïc générique de fin
[Musique]